vous allez être chef de la délégation du
Réseau Action Climat Canada pour cette
COP15 comment s'annonce les négociations
c'est une COP qui a lieu à alors que le
monde vit une série de crises une série
de tension géopolitique c'est un sommet
aussi qui a été repoussé quand même
plusieurs fois le sommeil se tient à
Montréal en fait à la dernière minute et
ensuite parce que on parle de la
décennie on est déjà en 2022 fin 2022 ce
qui nous indique en fait que qu'il va
falloir implanter ses objectifs là en
accéléré si on veut vraiment se rendre
en 2030 avec un bilan positif sur sur la
mise en oeuvre de politique en matière
de biodiversité comment se positionne le
Canada pour les négociations à venir le
Canada est au cœur de l'action parce que
on accueille la planète entière de ce
sommet on est quand même assez loin en
fait de d'avoir un bilan positif à
l'égard de la protection de la nature
donc si l'on veut se doter d'un visage
progressiste lors de la cocase il y aura
certainement un défi de cohérence pour
pour la participation du Canada lors de
ce sommet le Canada doit jouer le rôle
de pont de pont afin d'allier les
différentes forces progressistes et que
on se doute pas en fait d'un accord qui
soit le plus bas de dénominateur commun
mais au contraire que ce soit le plus
ambitieux possible et pour que ça arrive
il faut que le Canada revisent ces
positions et s'assure qu'à chaque moment
qu'on le demande ce soit le Canada en
premier qui exige le plus haut degré
d'ambition possible à la COP15 quel est
votre espoir pour la COP avenir moi je
souhaite que la COP15 devienne en fait
cette plateforme sur laquelle on peut
envoyer un message à la planète d'abord
avant tout que la crise sur la
biodiversité et la crise climatique on
doit s'y attaquer en même temps ensemble
deuxièmement qu'on peut pas le faire
s'il n'y a pas de justice climatique
justice sur la biodiversité
troisièmement qu'il faut s'assurer que
la mise en œuvre de toute politique en
matière de biodiversité elle doit
inclure les savoirs la connaissance et
la participation de votre autochtones
dans une approche des coloniale et on en
sait beaucoup nous en fait sur les
questions coloniales au Canada et
quatrièmement que le Canada le rôle du
Canada est clé pour s'assurer qu'on
puisse partir d'ici avec un cadre
ambitieux qui envoie un signal d'espoir
à la planète entière merci beaucoup et
tipérès